good morning so we just woke up and
we're gonna get ready for the day yeah
yeah I'm Sarah and I try to live
zero-waste with a baby being zero-waste
to me means not using single-use
plastics getting my food in my own
reusable containers or from the farmers
market package free and also composting
all of my food waste I started on mine
zero waste journey about five years ago
I also started a blog to chronicle all
my experiences to help other people on
their journey as well and I opened a
zero waste lifestyle shop a really
common image of zero wasters today are
you'll see like them carrying some trash
in a mason jar which is definitely
really admirable but I feel like can be
very intimidating as well and I
definitely make more trash than what
fits in a jar
sometimes my baby just wants to be
attached to me all day and I don't have
time or energy to make my own food so
sometimes I'll have someone deliver food
but the effort behind reducing my waste
I think is just as important in terms of
a baby a means using reusables instead
of disposable as like diapers and wipes
I'm really lucky that I can work part
time from home and I can breastfeed her
like on demand right now it's pretty
easy since she's only 3 months old that
she is just breastfed but I am already
looking into when she starts eating
solids and planning for snacks and
things like that and hopefully I can not
use disposables there as well we didn't
start out cloth diapering right when we
got home from the hospital I was
actually really intimidated at first
because nobody taught me how to use
cloth diapers I kind of just used
youtube videos and tutorials online to
figure it out but once we got into the
habit of it I really enjoyed it
because you're not constantly running
out and running out of diapers and
having to take out the trash all the
time we're having a trash can full of
stinky diapers instead I just do the
laundry it's really easy it's not a more
complicated way of do
laundry it's just like doing another
load of laundry here's my diaper caddy I
like to use pre folds and then here's
the inserts and some cloth wipes you
just fold this around the baby and then
you can use this thing here that has
plastic clasps on it and that will
secure the pre fold diaper on to her and
then to finish it off you just put a
wool cover on top and they also double
those pants wool naturally is
antibacterial and it wicks away any
moisture so you don't feel any dampness
on the outside and then the soiled
diaper I just throw into a wet bag right
here and that's it washing cloth diapers
is really easy I just rinsed them off
you can rinse them with a bidet attached
to your toilet and then once you are
ready to do a load you just put them in
the washing machine you don't have to
use any fancy detergent they probably do
laundry for heard diapers every other
day anytime we've used like a disposable
wipe you end up having to use so many
even though I just use these like
flannel pieces of fabric and then I just
let them with water you end up saving so
much money I mean like you can go
through a pack of wipes like really
quickly any time I've put like a
disposable on her and she goes number
two it always ends up in a blowout and
it like goes up I've tried different
brands different sizes and it's just I
don't know I've never had that issue
with cloth diapers though they seem to
absorb a lot more a typical day for us
is we wake up in the morning and I feed
her sometimes I will pump in the morning
and then give that a bottle to my
husband to feed her and then we play a
little bit
and change her diaper and kind of just
repeat that all day it's nap time she
fell asleep on top of me so I'll just be
hanging out so she's got a clean diaper
a clean clothes she's already taking her
first nap so now I have her in her
carrier and we can do some errands
around the house some chores now I'm
gonna do a load of laundry and it's all
just in this wet bag here you think I'd
just dump it all that making some tea
and some oats just in case I don't have
a chance to make anything really so I
did a load of laundry and I made some
food to eat I have made some tea for
myself and she ended up falling asleep
in the carrier so I'm going to do some
work on the computer okay
now we're at the farmers market and
we're just gonna get some vegetables for
the week just finished up with the
market and I put everything in my
reusable bag and my shopping cart and I
was also able to get a drink too today I
have a kale salad and I'm also has some
cabbage and some roasted sweet potato
that I got from the farmers market and
then I made
lemon tahini dressing and I'm just going
to top it off with some hemp parts that
I bought in a large bag but not from in
like a bulk section just because it's
harder for me to get to the grocery
store and fill all my bags of course the
hardest part is finding a time to eat it
because she's not happy right now okay
so I just put her to bed and now I have
some free time to do whatever I want
being zero waste the way that we are
today is not some sort of new concept
reusing and saving and buying secondhand
like these are things that our
grandparents have been doing for
generations I think about how I grew up
and how I was so fortunate to be able to
go camping and see all these great
national parks and experience nature and
it worries me that she might not get to
experience those same things and I want
to make sure that I'm doing things to
preserve the world around us the way
that I side
[Music]